the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
anyway today is gonna be a lot lighter
than the past few days which have been
heavy on theory and new stuff and I want
to focus today on what can you do with
the photon and ion interactions with
matter so we're gonna go through a whole
bunch of different analytical and
materials characterization techniques
that use the stuff that we've been
learning and see what you can actually
do and I'll be drawing from examples
from the open literature from textbooks
and from my own work so stuff I was
doing here on my PhD thesis there's
actually a direct result of what we do
here in 2201 so a quick review just to
get it all on the board of what we've
been looking at make sure I don't hit
anyone the way in we talked about
different photon interactions which
include the photoelectric effect let's
say this will be the energy of the
scattered whatever and this will be its
cross section we talked about Compton
scattering we talked about payer
production for the photoelectric effect
the energy of the photoelectron comes
off like the energy of the gamma ray -
some very small difference the binding
energy of the electron let's just call
it EB and this elects and this effect
starts when you hit what's called the
work function I'm just going to put this
all up there so when we explain the
analytical techniques we can point to
different bits of this and explain why
we use these different things the cross
section I made sure to keep this handy
so I don't want to lose it strongly
proportional with Z so the cross section
comes out okay you need another line
what was it proportional to oh yeah
this is nuts it's like Z to the fifth
over energy to the seven-halves which
says that for higher Z materials the
photoelectron yield is much much
stronger and it's way more likely at way
lower energy so you can imagine if you
wanted to use this in an analytical
technique and you want to study which
photo electrons come from which elements
you might think to use a low energy
photon to excite them not a high energy
photon because like we had done a couple
times before if we draw our energy
versus major cross-section range we had
a graph that looks something like this
where this was the photoelectric effect
this was Compton scattering
this is payer production and so by
knowing what energy and oh I'm sorry
that's supposed to be Z and this would
give you the dominant the dominant
process at each the combination of
energy and Z so if you know what energy
photons you've got and what you're
looking for oh there you go
let's see what was the energy of the
Compton electron
I remember the wavelength formula ah it
was like alpha one minus cosine theta
over let's see
another one minus cosine theta in came
the gamma ray energy what was the part
that came beforehand that's why I have
this here cuz I don't want to write
anything wrong it's good to have it all
up there at once one yeah that's all I
was missing cool and the cross-section
for Compton scattering scaled something
like Z over energy something pretty
simple not nearly as strong as pair
production or photoelectric effect so
you can think Compton scattering happens
much more dominantly at low Z or the
other two don't really happen that much
at low Z whichever way you want to think
of it and for pair production you get a
whole mess of stuff you get positrons
coming out you get a bunch of 511 ke V
gamma rays and all sorts of other things
you can detect and the cross section
this one's got the funny scaling term
yeah it's like Z squared log energy over
m ec squared so some Z squared kind of
dependence so let's keep those up for
now let's get the electron ones in
ah was it Z squared let me check
no that's a C yeah yeah I'll just make
sure that's a clearly a C squared so now
for let's call it charged particle or
just more generally ion electron
interactions since these are fresher
more fresh in our head what are the
three ways in which charged particles
can interact with matter that we talked
about just rattle off any one of them
yeah bremsstrahlung are radiative what
else
is what ionization which we'll call
inelastic collisions and yep Rutherford
scattering which are kind of elastic are
hard sphere collisions and if we had to
make kind of a table of when do we care
about which effect let's say this was an
ion or electron scattering off of either
electrons or nuclei in either elastic or
inelastic ways first of all when can
when do we actually care about elastic
scattering off of electrons which would
be hard sphere collisions off of
electrons to help to help get you going
in an elastic collision the maximum
energy transfer can be this formula
gamma times the incoming energy where
gamma is four times the incoming mass
times the mass of whatever you're
hitting over m plus Big M squared let's
say if one of these masses was mass of
an electron what is gamma approximately
equal for most cases
well let's say this was like electrons
scattering off of protons or vice-versa
how much energy could an electron
transfer to a proton in an elastic
collision basically zero the only time
which this actually matters is if it's
an electron hitting another electron in
which case you can have pretty
significant energy transfer so I'd say
for elastic collisions off of electrons
you only care about those four other
electrons and I'm gonna put in low
energy electrons why do we only care
about them for low energy electrons or
in other words what are the other
methods of stopping power or interaction
yeah Chris exactly yeah we already saw
that bremsstrahlung that the radiated
power scales with something like Z
squared over m squared so with a really
small mass and a really high Z and also
a higher energy you end up radiating
most of that power away as
bremsstrahlung and there's not much of a
chance of elastic collision so we only
care about low energy electrons when it
comes to elastic collisions with
electrons for inelastic collisions with
electrons well that's the hollow
cylinder derivation that we had done
from before where you have some particle
with a mass m and a charge little ze
getting slightly deflected by feeling
the pull depending on what charge it is
it could be towards or away of that
electron away from some impact parameter
B so we care about this pretty much all
the time
electrons and ions or stripped bare
nuclei actually matter in this case for
elastic collisions off of nuclei this is
what Rutherford scattering is it's a
simple hard simple hard sphere
collisions so this matter is pretty much
all the time
what about inelastic collisions with
nuclei what is an inelastic collision
actually mean with a nucleus
not so fusion could be one of them but
let's let's go more generally we have
some nuclear reaction where it's the old
thing that I keep drawing all the time
of some little nucleus striking a large
nucleus in an inelastic collision this
is the case we haven't considered yet
but I want to show you what actually
happens in an inelastic collision these
two nuclei joined together to form
what's called a compound nucleus or CN
at which point it breaks apart in some
other way so there might be some
different small particle and some
different large particle coming off but
in an inelastic collision it's almost
like the incoming particle is absorbed
and something else is remit 'add it
could be that same particle at a
different energy and it could be a
different energy altogether so yeah I'd
say fusion is an example it's kicked off
by an inelastic collision because you've
got to have some sort of absorption
event of the small nucleus by the big
nucleus and then maybe if it fuses and
just stays that way it releases a ton of
its binding energy well that's pretty
cool so these actually do matter but not
for all energies in all cases so let's
go back to the Janus database of
cross-sections to see when inelastic
scattering actually matters bring us
back to normal size and we'll look at
some of the cross-sections to see when
do we actually care about inelastic
scattering so we haven't selected a
database yet let's say we're firing
protons at things and we'll pick a
database that actually has some elements
listed not a lot but iron that works so
we can look at the difference between
the elastic scattering cross-section and
the anything cross-section so the red
curve here and I make it thicker easily
probably oh yeah I can make it thicker
pretty
so it's easier to see plotz wait
aha that's not what I wanted I'm not
gonna mess around in this anymore can
you guys see the two lines okay so this
is the elastic scattering cross-section
kind of funny to see it negative but
then there's the anything cross-section
which picks up at around three MeV or so
and it usually takes somewhere between
one and ten MeV for inelastic scattering
to quote-unquote turn on and that's
because you have to be able to excite
the nucleus to some next energy level so
sending in a proton at like 0.01 MeV is
not going to excite any of the internal
particles to a higher energy level so if
you want to see some pretty interesting
cases let's go to incident Neutron data
where we have a ton of this data and
I'll show you some examples yeah we got
lots more data for neutrons so now we
can look at some of these cross-sections
like this Z and prime let's take a look
at what that looks like that means a
neutron comes in different Neutron comes
out notice that the scale only starts at
862 ke V so let's make it something else
oh my look at that nothing going on
until you reach almost 1 MeV which means
hey an elastic scattering doesn't really
turn on until that so I would say that
this can matter but for higher energy
collisions so yeah it matters pretty
much all the time but higher energy
collisions and there's actually yeah
only for low energy electrons yeah so
for the that's the refer that the sort
of compound reason that I and Chris said
one is that you can't transfer much mass
in an elastic collision
I'm sorry much energy in an elastic
collision unless the masses are close
enough to each other and two at higher
energies the electron radiates
bremsstrahlung much much much faster as
we saw at around 10 MeV bremsstrahlung
and inelastic scattering give about
equal contributions to the stopping
power for Heisey materials like lead so
once you're down and let's say like the
KETV range yeah electron elastic
collisions might matter so we talked
about those three now I think we can
launch into the analytical technique so
for the rest of the lecture today it's
all gonna be what can you do with the
stuff that we've been learning since the
first exam I know it hasn't been long
since but we've actually learned a ton
and I want to show you what's actually
possible and this is not gonna be with
slides it's all live from websites that
I'd love for you guys to be able to
follow a long way there check out at
home so I'm going to show you an awesome
resource through the MIT libraries and
how to get there if you go to veera
mit.edu there's a great tool called the
ASM handbook you can see I've been there
before
there's the ASM handbooks online and
this is kind of that's everything to
know about material science metallurgy
and analytical techniques absolutely
everything from corrosion to fracked
ography to characterization to structure
of materials to where you can find every
single alloy to binary phase diagrams of
how things mix and we're gonna head to
one of these handbooks number nine or
ten materials characterization because
with the stuff that's on this board you
can understand how most materials
characterization techniques work and I
want to show you a few of them one of
which no two of which we're gonna demo
out next Friday's recitation so I think
I told you guys in the syllabus and
probably in person that we're going to
try out some scanning electron
microscopy and some energy
dispersive x-ray or EDX analysis so with
the x-ray transition stuff you've
learned you actually know how to
elementally analyze different materials
and with scanning electron microscopy
you can get some idea about how
electrons can make images much better
than optical images so let's head to
electron optical methods scanning
electron microscopy and show you what
one of these things actually looks like
let's take a look at an SEM or scanning
electron microscope so up at the top
there's a device called the electron gun
for now just imagine it's a source of
electrons but in a few minutes we'll
actually explain how it works using the
principle of thermionic emission which
we talked about last Friday you've got
some electronic lenses some focusing
coils that cause this beam to get
focused further and further so let's say
you have this electron filament giving
off electrons in all directions when you
see boxes with X's like this on an
electron optics diagram it usually means
this is like a focusing coil of some
sort so that will cause the electrons to
get bent and focused there'll be another
set of coils that focuses them further
and some scanning coils that actually
raster or XY scan this beam across the
surface of a material and so in this way
what you're actually doing is putting
the electron beam at one part of your
material and then with another detector
let's call it a secondary electron
detector looking at the electrons
produced from collisions with those
other electrons that then get detected
here and the number of electrons
produced at any point gives you the
brightness of the image that's kind of
as simple as it is despite how
complicated this diagram looks there's
an electron source there's coils that
scan it back and forth like has anyone
ever seen the old cathode ray tube or
CRT televisions there's gonna be this
kind of come a day when that answer's no
and I'm kind of worried for that because
the day that's the day I'll officially
become old
but for now everyone's seen a CRT and
not actually word the way that actually
works that there's an electron gun that
fires and scans left to right and up to
down or raster's and produces that
electron image in an SEM you use an
electron gun kind of similar and then
collect the electrons generated in the
specimen what's called secondary
electrons and the number that you see
gives you the brightness of the image
the cool thing is this actually allows
you to look at both secondary electron
contrast and topology of a sample so
let's say this was your secondary
electron detector and you had an
electron beam scanning across your
sample to some of those peaks and
valleys and I'll probably draw one right
here for a good reason let's say the
electrons hit right here and you send
out a wave of secondary electrons the
material partly determines how many
electrons come off but also so does the
geometry they'll usually be a little
cage with some sort of a positive
voltage on it to attract those secondary
electrons and some of them will curve
into the detector and become part of
your signal but some of them won't
meanwhile if you have this beam right
here producing secondary electrons
pretty much all of them go slamming into
your detector and that's what actually
allows the electron microscope to get
topology
that's why images in the SEM look fairly
3d so I want to show you a few examples
from my own boredom when I was doing a
lot of was it science there we go it's a
whole gallery of SEM images when I was
supposed to be doing something better Oh
No 404
my websites broken oh yeah this is also
what you do when you're bored right make
your own 404 page ha my SEM galleries
are dead well that's okay I have other
images ready to show you guys so this is
a neat this is a a paper that I
published out of my PhD work that shows
the real difference between optical and
electron microscopy part of it is the
limit of your resolution depends on the
wavelength or debroglie wavelength of
the thing you're using to make the image
so an optical microscope in this case
you can't get better resolution than
about half a micron because even the
blue wavelengths of light are getting
down into about the 450 nanometer regime
and it's very difficult without
interference techniques or other fancy
things to beat that diffraction limit to
beat the sort of wavelength limit of
optical microscopy so this is a 500 X
optical microscope image and you can see
these little fingers in this case it's
liquid lead bismuth penetrating into a
stainless steel that we were doing
corrosion experiments on and that's as
good as the image can get in an optical
microscope switch down to an SEM and
then all of a sudden the picture becomes
much much much more clear you can start
to see things the the best SCM we have
in our lab has an ultimate resolution of
about one nanometer now resolution is
kind of a funny thing it's neat to tell
you what that means it doesn't mean that
if you have a pattern of lines that are
exactly one nanometer thick that you
will see them as lines one nanometer
thick it means that if you then plot
let's say your signal or your brightness
versus X you'll have some barely
distinguishable and fuzzy lines just
enough for you to say those are two
optically distinct features so what
you'll actually see in a one nanometer
microscope
is maybe something like this that's
technically resolved at the level of one
nanometer so the best you can do for
crisp objects in this thing is about
twenty nanometers not bad it's like a
something that's a few thousand atoms on
a side pretty cool and so what you can
see in here is liquid lead bismuth
penetrating into this stainless steel
and you notice a few different things
this image was taken in backscatter
electron mode back scattering is we've
talked about this before when you have a
scattering event where theta equals pi
we call that back scatter and
let's kind of split this into regular
and back scatter for back scattering the
cross-section for this is proportional
to Z squared another one of those
extremely Z dependent cross-sections
which means that the larger the Z the
higher the atomic number the more back
scatter contrast you get so if you want
to figure out where the little lead
whiskers are penetrating into the
stainless steel since lead has a Z of
like 82 and iron has a Z of like 26 it
shows up like night and day you have a
question Julia okay yeah so this is
something we'll actually be able to do
so for the two folks I asked to bring in
samples if you want to bring in
something with very different elements
in it we should be able to see it and
back scatter contrast very very clearly
and in the image of the SEM I'll go back
to that which one of these pages was it
aha notice here that there is a
backscatter detector so it will detect
which of those electrons scatter back at
almost 180 degrees and that's a bit
about Z squared proportionality super
useful tool because if you want to see
for example where the circuit board
traces are and you want to look at
aluminum versus oxygen contrasts that'll
help you really well if you want to see
where is Len penetrating into stainless
steel it shines up clear as day just
pretty fun the other thing the electrons
will do when they enter into a material
is excite lots of things so anything
from x-rays 2oj electrons so now I'd
like to bring up Oh J electron
spectroscopy so electron or x-ray
spectroscopic methods Oh J electron
spectroscopy it's not just a thing to
trip you up on the exam or a little
minutia from radioactive decay it's
actually incredibly useful because of
where the Oh J electrons are generated
and what they tell you about the
material so as a
quick refresher normally you could have
let's say if a photon comes in and
ejects a photoelectron as another
electron comes to fill that hole either
an x-ray will be emitted or an oj
electron will be emitted and it's those
oj electrons their outer binding energy
electrons they have very low binding
energy which means see keep running out
of room you know what I'm not gonna draw
it I'm just gonna show you because I
know there's a diagram of what I want to
show you here if you want to see where
the o'shea electrons are actually
produced in a material there we go since
there's such low energy the only Oh J
electrons that actually get out would be
in this outer few monolayers in fact
there's some oj electron energies that
can only get out one or two atomic
monolayers from a material so it's one
of the best surface analysis techniques
that we have you can both use o j
electrons to make an electron image like
any other SEM and you can collect them
and measure their energy to figure out
which elements they came from and this
kind of teardrop shape is a one it's a
great synthesis of all the information
you need to know in the SEM that we'll
see on Friday and - it's why people
screw up SEM analysis a lot a lot of the
x-ray excitation happens down here why
do you think that the x-ray excitation
would happen near the end of the path of
the electron beam from what you know
about stopping power
or if I asked you to draw a graph of
let's say energy versus stopping power
for ionization what would it look like
yeah yep yep yep sort of flattens out
and then eventually starts picking up
again but not very much
so as the energy of whatever you're
going into
I'm sorry whatever particle you're
sending in gets lower its stopping power
increases and you have a much higher
chance of this ionization happening
especially in the case of electrons I
usually come in at between 10 and 40 kV
and so near the end of their range is
where they produce a lot of the x-rays
now there's a lot of other nuances to
saying well which x-rays were produced
here and what elements are they from
let's say you had the same material here
or here fewer x-rays will get out of the
bottom region than they will from the
top region so if you happen to be
analyzing something that has a gradient
in composition or a changing composition
from the top to the bottom
you might this be like oh well I have a
few nano meters of oxygen on silicon why
aren't I seeing any oxygen x-rays
because you're probably generating them
down here that's one of those things to
note so sometimes you'll see and elect a
an elemental map of things that shows
x-rays of certain element coming from
somewhere and you can't see it at all in
the image that's because they might be
underneath what you can see on the image
it's kind of tricky like that I'll show
you some examples of what those maps
look like also from this paper so from
from the electron image we kind of we
sort of concluded all right lead is
probably penetrating into the stainless
steel how do we know for sure you can
make EDX or elemental dispersive I'm
sorry energy dispersive x-ray maps by
focusing the electron beam at one point
collecting all the different x-rays and
then moving from one point to another to
see when do you get characteristic
x-rays from each of those elements so
you can actually prove to say yes those
little fingers are indeed bismuth and
lead and you can see that in this case
where the blood and bismuth is the iron
is not but the curious thing we found is
that in this whole band right here
most of the chromium disappeared so it
turns out that the corrosion mechanism
was chromium dissolution and we would
not have been able to know that without
this EDX mapping and without
understanding how the edx maps are made
from the electrons interacting with
matter and producing characteristic
x-rays would have been able to prove
this so yet another example where the
basic stuff you're learning in 2201 is
the theoretical underpinning of the
techniques that we use all the time of
material science which i thought was
pretty cool
got more examples of that that are even
more striking because I let it collect
for a little longer
you can actually see right here that
where the bismuth is the iron isn't but
the iron is not dissolving the chromium
is it's just the leaded bismuth they're
kind of sucking the chromium out of the
metal right there and that's what making
the stainless steel less stainless it's
pretty neat
then on to EDX analysis what sort of
information are we looking at at every
one of these pixels I have a couple of
other example x-ray spectra so now we're
in a position to understand why one of
these x-ray spectra looks the way it
does in this case we're firing electrons
atom material so whereas our material
we're firing at it right here
so we're firing in electrons and in some
cases let's say we had an iron atom that
electron can eject another electron and
then one of those other electrons will
fall down in that shell giving off a
characteristic x-ray in this case since
it's from the third to the second shell
that would be what we call an L x-ray
or a something to level-2 transition and
every element has got its characteristic
x-ray transitions like we saw on the
nist
x-ray transition database and since we
know what all those are we know where to
expect them so we know where we expect
to see chromium's x-rays and iron's
x-rays gold kind of an interesting one
we are there's two things about doing
analysis with gold a lot of times you
have to coat your materials in gold to
boost their a secondary electron
contrast but also gold's i think it's
its l line or m line I forget which one
is the same as Argon's
k line and we have an expression in the
electron microscopy world the
probability of finding argon and your
sample decreases with experience takes a
second to parse that chances are if
you're looking at a solid material you
don't have argon in it but there are
x-ray lines that overlap with each other
like the L line for gold and the K line
for argon are at pretty much the same
energy certainly similar enough that
it's within the resolution or like full
width half maximum of these two peaks so
remember how we were analyzing the
uncertainty of our banana spectra with
the FWHM or full width at half maximum
same thing here and you can really see
that the energy resolution of this
detector is not the best so if you see a
peak it might be due to two or more
Peaks crowding in that right there and
with a lot of Correction factors that I
won't get into you can then use this
information to integrate the area under
these Peaks and get elemental analysis
so you can say how much chromium or how
much iron and silicon is in one of these
samples what's this stuff here on the
bottom anyone tell me
that continuum of observed x-ray
energies Compton scattering is a photon
effect so that would be if if this were
a Compton well if this were a um a
photon analysis spectrum then you would
see something like this but of a
different shape you'd have that Compton
Bowl with an edge but this is in this
case electrons interacting with material
what do you think's causing that broad
background well what are the different
ways in which electrons can interact
with matter
you've seen the ionizations here we're
not really seeing Rutherford scattering
what's left bremsstrahlung yep that's
exactly it
so the observed Bream Cerrone spectrum
follows this sort of characteristic peak
early and then tail off curve what's the
actual bremsstrahlung spectrum that we
are not sensing what would it look like
so always running out of room if this is
what we're actually observing let's say
we have a few Peaks that would be
intensity and that would be energy
what's really going on physically that
we're not seeing yeah
mm-hmm that's right you actually should
get more low-energy bremsstrahlung one
of some of the reasons you don't is that
the lower energy those x-rays come out
the more they get absorbed self absorbed
in the material in the few gas molecules
in the SEM and in the window of the
detector so just because this is what
you see doesn't mean this is what's
actually going on in your material if we
think back then to where the electrons
and x-rays are generated the x-rays that
are generated down here the lower energy
ones are going to be shielded more and
this kind of messes up your elemental
analysis because if you the x-rays
produced here proportionally more of the
low-energy ones will get out than the
ones produced here so as you change your
as you change your electron beam energy
you might see your elemental composition
appear to change when you know it's
really not and that's because where the
x-rays are being generated change and
proportionally more of the low-energy
ones get self shielded by your material
so you actually have to correct for that
and input your beam energy into the edx
analyzer so it knows how to correct for
this but with the understanding of
you've been giving you guys in this
class you can understand like well why
can you get screwed up why do we have to
have all these correction factors so I
think it's pretty neat then let's get on
to some of the other methods like x-ray
photoelectron spectroscopy or XPS this
is something I hinted to a little bit
earlier that actually uses the
photoelectric effect because it's a
photoelectron spectroscopy method
this one's incredibly useful because not
only does it tell you what elements are
there but in what binding state they are
because photo electron spectrometer can
be incredibly precise the energy
equation should look pretty familiar to
you it's whatever a photo electron you
get is the gamma ray energy that comes
in minus the binding energy of that
electron
and the work function and so you can
very very simply figure out for a given
element and a given electron shell what
photoelectron energies do you expect so
you can collect them so I'll show you
another example from this paper where we
started to do that we wanted to answer
the question what are the oxides forming
on the stainless steel when lead
corrodes it and just telling you which
elements are there and in what
proportion doesn't give the answer
because what if there's multiple phases
of each oxide like for example iron can
take forms like Fe o Fe 2 O 3 Fe 3 o 4
and this FeO can actually have a range
of stoichiometry so how do you know you
don't know there could be like scores of
phases of this iron oxide and the
question is how you know which ones are
there the photoelectrons will tell you
so what you can do first is fire
monochromatic x-rays so single energy
x-rays in this case from aluminum at
your material and see which photo
electrons of which energy come off and
you can tell which atomic shell they're
from and which elements they should be
to a very high precision in this case
this is done to 100 Mille MeV or zero
point 1 MeV precision 0.1 evey precision
so we can tell not only what elements
are there
but what shells they came from then you
can get even crazier you can scan very
slowly over one of these Peaks with
point zero zero one evey precision and
start to see something pretty cool if
you look at the carbon 1s electrons you
can see that there are actually three of
them only a couple of evie apart and
this corresponds to different binding
States of molecules with that carbon for
an even more subtle example but ended up
being incredibly important for us here's
one of the chromium 2p shell Peaks you
can actually see there's three of them
superimposed give that funny-looking
peak shape right there what that
actually tells us is that there's
chromium
in three different binding states in
that oxide and the ones we figured out
must be there we saw the ones
corresponding to CR 2 O 3 Fe CR 2 O 4
and I forget which other one but we have
them tabulated there we go oh wow
Fe 2 point 4 CR 0 point 604 known
crystallographic phases of these oxides
so you can look at the peaks found to a
resolution of like a hundredth of an
electron volt compared to reference
values taken on pure compounds and
materials to figure out what actual
oxides do you have that can help tell
you things like how protective are they
how fast are they going to grow and are
they going to be a problem if you want
to use this new stainless steel that we
developed in the lead bismuth reactor
it's the biggest problem with lead
bismuth reactors is lead corrodes like
everything and so the whole point of my
graduate studies was design an alloy
that doesn't corrode and lead and make
it a lloyd composite out of it but you
can't prove that it works unless you not
only know how fast it corrodes but how
it corrodes which oxides form and in
what order that's the last part I
haven't told you about yet is what order
so I want to switch to another technique
called secondary ion mass spectroscopy
or Sims in this case you start off with
firing ions out of material which will
then eject or sputter away secondary
ions in this case this process of
sputtering let's say this is your
material here you send in something like
oxygen ions which might be like Oh to
minus with a mass of 32 and then you
blast off or sputter away a few atoms at
a time from that surface and they'll
come off the various masses and charges
and in this case this sputtering could
be due to Rutherford scattering because
you might directly ballistically slam an
ion out of the surface then every one of
these ions has a different mass and a
different
charge and by sending it through a mass
spectrometer something that separates
these materials by their mass to charge
ratio because the higher the charge the
more deflected and ion will be but the
higher the mass the less deflected it
will be that should sound really
familiar in our idea here where how
these ionization collisions happen if
you remember the higher the charge the
stronger the Coulomb force that q1 q2
over R squared I think there was a
constant in there so the higher the
charge the higher those queues and the
stronger the Coulomb forces but the
larger the mass is the less momentum it
can impart and so the deflection will be
weaker exact same things happening here
and you can separate out atoms not only
by their charge in their mass but
specifically by their isotope so this is
one of those ways that you can figure
out make an isotopic map of a material
in three dimensions you can scan your
ion beam across the material and collect
the ions at every point and as you
sputter you slowly wear away layers of
this material and so you can actually
reconstruct a 3d map with almost
nanometre precision of every single
isotope that was at every location which
is quite cool as you can see that these
master charge ratios can depend on which
isotope of silicon you have what sort of
cluster what molecule what charge you
have and you can do some pretty crazy
analysis of things to even figure out
what sort of compounds exist on surfaces
because sometimes you sputter off whole
molecules they're gonna have their own
mass to charge ratio and that's what we
did for this led bismuth work lots of
XPS spectra to jump through we wanted to
find out which oxides were forming and
in what order which one's the best one I
want to show I think it's this one
so in this case we used setup we used
ion sputtering to sputter away surface
layers to a depth of a few hundred
nanometers and we're actually able to
show that the chromium oxide right here
was on the outside of the sample
followed by silicon oxide followed by
iron metal so in this way we were able
to figure out using XPS the nature of
the oxides and using Simms the order of
the oxides so not only how fast were
they growing to nanometre precision but
in what order did they form and that
helped us figure out this sort of
synergistic chromium and silicon
oxidation mechanism that helps really
protect the layers of the stainless
steel and explain why it's corrosion
resistant and led bismuth all using
principles from 2201 so it's about 205
of so I wanted to stop and see if you
guys have any questions on these
analytical techniques knowing that we're
actually going to go do a couple of
these next Friday does anyone use any of
these before yeah which ones views
and
SEM and XPS okay cool yeah we've got all
these instruments I think except for
Sims here at MIT yeah yeah
this would be the energy of the Compton
electron that comes out when a photons
scat when a photon scatters off of it so
the photon will end up losing some
energy and the Compton electron will
pick up that energy sorry
it's a 1 plus alpha times 1 minus cosine
theta where alpha I'll mention what
alpha is it's a ratio of the photon
energy to the electron mass rest mass
energy sure this is kind of a nice on
these two boards right here it's kind of
a nice summary of the stuff we've been
doing over the last three weeks or so
and then all the stuff I showed you
today is what you can do with it